if you write badly for instance I'm
trying to think of a good example how
about when I wrote my book when I had
trimmed it down nice and tight and I
thought I really had it ready to go I
had a hundred and hundred and twenty
hundred and thirty thousand words in the
manuscript and I called him up and said
okay I'm ready to go I've done my
cutting and I've done them to it you
know here it is one hundred thirty
thousand words and he laughed publisher
laughed and said no no Eric we don't
publish anything over seventy thousand
words and it was like this boat of
horror that hit me I said wait a minute
are you actually telling me that I now
have to cut my book in half and he said
yeah actually I'm afraid I am so for
three or four days I was just
practically in a coma but you know any
writer you know you're just you're up
all the way what they make you to do to
your babies and then I got some help I
had somebody else a dear dear friend who
was good with editing take a look at it
and I seriously cut into it one more
time for editing I got it down to 82
thousand words not quite there seventy
thousand but I cut it by forty
forty-five percent of the book that I
thought was absolutely necessary was
gone and the book was better for it it
was such a better book it was clearer
and it was cleaner and there were so
many swamps removed from it it was an
interesting experience but I had did not
realize then you know you have to reject
if I I didn't realize how much work that
was yet to be done so writing is word
choices and a process of really cool too
which means writers never write alone
never but what we spend a lot of time
alone in the writing process but once we
have
something then we have to and this is
important this is important to two new
writers everywhere you have to have a
circle of people use opinion of material
you trust it's one of the things that
happens in our program these people make
friends for life because then they rely
on each other's judgment because
everybody knows everybody's opinion
grows to become quite sophisticated
about the material and you can always
call up one of your buddies and say you
want to do a script swap you know you
read mine I read yours and what you get
back frequently is not what you want to
hear we're all children and we all want
to say oh that is the greatest thing
isn't that great and that's never what
you hear so you're always eternally
disappointed so you hear objective good
criticism of what you've got and I
always tell them 48 hours don't do
anything for 48 hours suffer fine you
stay in bed whatever you need to do in
response to what you've heard about your
material and then sit down and read it
again cover to cover and it will be
revealed to you through someone else's
point of view what you really have and
all of a sudden it's time to start
editing again and rewriting again you
will get it and that is what has
happened there is the cycle of
subjective work to re objectification
because the more you work on something
over time the more you are in it you are
drawn into it and it becomes within you
and it is about you and you think you're
doing something great and then you take
it out and you get a slap in the face or
two you get you clears your eyes it
clears your vision very very well you
become reified and you approach the
material again with clean eyes for
another go-round and in my experience if
you really want good material and I'm
assuming we all do there's some we just
want that's on the head and all kind of
stuff but if you really want the
material to be good you have to go
through that cycle subjectivity Lea
vacation subjectivity rehabbed four or
five maybe six times then then each time
you know it gets better and it gets a
little better and they catch a little
better and you don't want to send that
anything out it's one of the biggest
mistakes people make sending out
material before it's finished
so if you're giving writers too
permission to write badly
and you're doing these exercises and
that's one of the first things you write
on the board where what permission are
you giving them with the rewrites and
how open are they to rewriting most of
them get I mean it's a cliche but please
cliches are cliches because they're true
that writing is rewriting and the only
real way to teach writing is through
editing that's why I spend a great deal
of time on scripts and sample editing
and scratching out stuff and throwing
out scenes and telling them people you
don't need this this is good expand it
here and all that kind of stuff because
it's it's stuff that people truly need
to hear that's what you get in a
concentrated two-year four semester
program you get a heck of a lot of
practice in in a very short period of
time surrounded by very knowledgeable
people who can guide you is there wear
and tear on the nervous system you bet
that's that's kind of built in and
guaranteed but I so far I've never heard
anybody say they regret it or anybody
complain about it when they come out the
other end but the other thing I write on
the board a few weeks later yeah a few
weeks later is there is no such thing as
a bad screenplay
only an unfinished one and this is
something I believe truly believe just
strongly as I believe about writing you
got to write badly with pride or you're
never going to write anything it's
written you know you have to allow
yourself to do that but I think any idea
for a screenplay that is console
based you know this is the essential it
has to be conflict based but any idea
for a screenplay that is conflict based
can be made to work it can and bad
screenplays if they contain some
conflict they can all be made to work
it's just that they're sent out before
they're finished and when you send
something out before it's really
finished you really only get one good
shot at it and we kind of burn it up and
a lot of good ideas have gone to the
idea cemetery because it's up making
that move
you